the number of three by three matrices a
whose entries are either zero or one and
for which the system a times the vector
or we can kind of call it the the three
by one matrix xyz is equal to one zero
zero has exactly two distinct solutions
is so let's think about this a little
bit let me define let me just so we make
sure we understand what this is saying
let me define my vector a or sorry my
matrix a it's a 3 by 3 matrix as a b c
d
e f
g h i just all lower case letters these
are the actual entries in the matrix and
if that's the case then this equation
would be this thing this is a
times
times
x y z
times x y z
being equal to
being equal to
1
0 0 and if we were to multiply out this
expression over here or if we were to
multiply out this equation we would get
a times x plus b times y plus c times z
is equal to 1. and we can do that for
each of these rows this
this row vector dotted with this column
vector is going to be equal to zero this
row vector dotted with this column
vector is going to be equal to zero and
if that's very unfamiliar to you you
might want to watch the linear algebra
playlist we go into a lot of detail on
multiplying matrices and vectors and
solving equations of this this variety
but this if we were to multiply it out
we would get so if we multiplied this
part out we would get ax
plus so a times x plus b times y
plus b times y plus c times z is equal
to
is equal to one
we would get
d times x
d times x plus
e times y
e times y
plus f times z is equal to
zero
and we would get g times so this right
over here we would get g
times x
plus h times y plus h times y
plus i times z is going to be equal to
zero
now this is a this is the
the exact same equation as this right
here i've just expressed it as three
equations with three unknowns or another
way to think about it is
any solution any solution to these three
equations would essentially represent a
point in three dimensions that is common
to these three planes each of these
equations represent a plane and here we
just have to think about it what are
what are all of the possible solutions
we could have
now there is a situation where there is
a solution where these planes intersect
in exactly one point so you could have
the blue plane the blue plane might go
like this
the blue plane might look like this
the orange plane
maybe intersects like this let me do
that in orange
the orange plane
might come out like this
so it'll intersect like that
it'll go below it like that
and then maybe the green plane
maybe the green plane intersects like
this
it doesn't have to be they don't have to
go at right angles like this
but this
is easier for me to draw so then the
green plane intersects like that
and they would all intersect at that
point and that point would represent the
solution so this is one possibility
where you have one solution so this is
what the one solution
this would mean having
this would mean having one solution
now there's the other situation in which
there's no solutions there's possibility
that there's no solutions where they
don't intersect in one point and a
pretty straightforward way to imagine
that is kind of a triangle so maybe this
is
so let me draw it like this this is the
blue plane
this is the blue plane like this
and then the orange plane
the orange plane might come in like let
me draw it as best as i can
might come out like this
come out like that then go down go under
like that
and then the green plane the green plane
might cut across like this
the green try my best to draw it
the green plane might look like this
where it cuts across it's kind of a like
a tp or pyramid or where the green plane
intersects like that so these three
planes do not intersect in any one point
they each intersect with one other plane
in an or they each intersect in the
other with the other two planes in an
infinite number of points but there's
not one point in three dimensions that
satisfies all three planes this this
point right here it satisfies the green
and the blue plane not the orange plane
or the green and the blue equations not
the orange equation the this point right
here satisfies the blue and the orange
equation not the green equation this
point over here satisfies the green and
orange equations but not the blue
equations so this right here this is the
case of no solutions no
solutions
and then the final circumstance that you
could have is an infinite number of
solutions and that especially so you can
imagine these actually well they can't
all three be the same equation because
this one has a one here but this one has
zeros here but these two these two could
be the same equation they could
represent they could represent one
they could represent the same exact
plane
they could represent the same exact
plane
so let's say they both represent this
magenta plane over here and then you
have this blue
you have this blue thing over here the
blue plane
the blue plane may be coming out like
this
the blue plane coming out like this
like that they're kind of forming this x
and so you can imagine in this situation
you have an infinite number of solutions
you have an infinite number any point
here any point at the intersection of
these two planes would be a solution so
you would have an infinite infinite
number infinite
infinite infinite solutions and that
would even be the case that would even
be the case if this was if these were if
these were all zeros if d e f and g h
and i were all zeros then any x y and z
would satisfy them so it would really
kind of reduce to uh kind of being all
of r three and so anything that
satisfies the top equation would satisfy
all three because if you put these there
it would all be zero so as you see
and maybe you already realized this
before that if you have if you have
three planes intersecting you can either
have one solution no solutions or an
infinitely many solutions another way to
have no solutions is if two of these
planes are parallel or maybe this is
maybe these coefficients are zero zero
and zero zero x plus zero y plus zero z
is equal to 1. well no x y and z is
going to satisfy that so that would be
another no solutions case but no matter
what you do you're either going to have
one solution no solutions or infinite
solutions now this question is asking us
is asking us
find the number of matrices a the number
of three by three matrices a whose
entries are either zero or one so sure
all these coefficients are either zero
one that has exactly two distinct
solutions what i just showed you you
either have one solution no solutions or
infinite solutions you cannot have
exactly two distinct solutions so the
number of three by three matrices that
has exactly two solutions to this
equation is a big
zero